Let’s talk about everyone’s big hope.
A coronavirus vaccine for all and treatments for the sick.
Hundreds of vaccines and drugs
are being tested around the world in record time.
What we're trying to do is to take something
that usually takes 15 years
and truncate it down to a few months.
We all have questions.
And some of you sent us yours.
When can we expect a vaccine?
Who will get it first?
How much will it cost?
And here’s one from us
do we need a vaccine to get back to our normal lives?
There is no cure for SARS-CoV-2
the coronavirus that causes the disease COVID-19.
But a vaccine and the right drugs
can help our bodies fight it.
So this is what we’re up against.
The virus has a crown of spikes
made of protein molecules.
They attach to human cells and act like a key in a lock
that lets the virus in.
Once inside the virus hijacks
the cell’s reproductive machinery
to make copies of itself.
A vaccine protects you by mimicking
a small part of the virus.
We would take a little part of that protein surface
of the virus killing the virus and we would inject it
into people to see if they would make antibodies to it.
If that real virus came in then the antibody
would immediately recognise it
and would immediately take care of it.
But there are different ways of making a vaccine.
Some labs are taking the more traditional route.
They’re testing whether introducing
different parts of the spike protein into humans
can trigger an immune response.
But this sort of protein-based vaccine typically takes years
to develop because scientists have to grow the protein
and test it’s safe.
So other labs are working on a different strategy
that’s never been done before.
It involves copying a small section
of the virus’s RNA genetic code
and injecting that into a person.
That RNA fragment then instructs human cells
to reproduce certain coronavirus proteins
and hopefully that triggers an immune response.
Using the RNA approach means you don’t have to grow
the coronavirus protein in a lab
the body does all the hard work.
Hopefully this will take months out of the process
and will get us a vaccine sooner.
But again we're in uncharted territory here.
Now usually a vaccine takes up to 10 or even 15 years to test
manufacture and distribute
if a vaccine candidate even makes it that far.
But we don't have that kind of time.
Labs around the world got to work
as soon as a Chinese scientist published
the virus’s genetic sequence in January.
It's a game with high stakes.
Governments, public institutions, philanthropists
they’re all involved.
Private companies in places like the US
China and Germany — they’re all competing.
But some researchers are also working together
on open platforms.
We haven't seen such an acceleration
in sharing information and sharing data.
To give you an idea of how fast things are moving
it took seven months to start human trials
during the Zika epidemic.
That was a record.
For this new coronavirus it took just 63 days.
But testing on people is just one step.
The manufacturing, I think, is going to be the real challenge.
And we need to make sure
that we're ramping that up right now
alongside the clinical trials that are under way.
Based on most estimates we could get a new vaccine
sometime early next year.
But it’ll take longer for it to get to millions of people.
One of the vaccine makers Johnson & Johnson
says that won’t happen before late next year.
And there’s going to be a bottleneck.
So who gets it first?
During the H1N1 swine flu in 2009
one of the first vaccines was made in Australia.
The government was criticised
for making sure it went to Australians first.
The concern this time around is that countries
will want to do the same thing again.
And there’s reason for that concern.
Right now there is no international body
to police distribution of a vaccine.
Not even the WHO has that power.
Nor is there a global plan for a co-ordinated rollout.
Groups like the GAVI vaccine alliance and CEPI, though
are working to get vaccines to developing countries.
And the WHO has emergency rules in place
that were set up during the Ebola epidemic.
They say any new vaccine should first go to the people
who need it most — like frontline workers.
There’s also pressure on the pharmaceutical industry
not to chase big profits.
Millions of people need the vaccine
so the demand will be huge.
And governments can’t afford to pay top dollar.
The thing is vaccines are expensive to make.
CEPI and the Wellcome Trust think it’ll cost the industry
$3 billion to develop, manufacture
and distribute a vaccine globally.
It might be worthwhile for a private company
to make it have a good standing in the public eye
to say we're going to do this at a reduced cost
this is a humanitarian thing.
The Gates foundation is likely going to blow
billions of dollars to build production facilities
for seven vaccine candidates
knowing some of those vaccines
won’t make the grade.
The idea is to ensure we’re ready to go
once a vaccine is found.
We will make it as cheap as we can.
And there is no doubt the money will be — should be
found to buy that vaccine for everyone on the planet.
A vaccine is the long-term goal.
So right now scientists are using
experimental treatments to help people
already sick with COVID-19.
Like plasma therapy which involves collecting antibodies
from people who’ve recovered
and injecting them into infected patients.
They’re also trying out drugs in early development
or already on the market for other diseases
like the antiviral remdesivir that was developed for Ebola
or hydroxychloroquine used for malaria.
There are many candidates therapeutics or drugs
that are showing some promise or potential.
But we need to be exceptionally careful.
It’s extremely important that we rely on the results
that are going to come from trials that will tell us how safe
and effective these drugs are.
And then there are the so-called treatments
that have raised alarm bells.
The idea of injecting disinfectant
got lots of laughs online.
I think most people are smart enough to know
that they shouldn't be taking medical
or public health advice from President Trump
they should be listening to expert opinion.
With every vaccine or drug there’s a calculated risk.
With measles for instance your chance of dying
from the disease is about one in a thousand.
But the chances of having an adverse reaction
to the vaccine are less than one in a million.
Any medical response is going to be experimental
and might come with side effects.
Because no drug or vaccine has been licensed
for this coronavirus.
It’s new.
But we also know that vaccines
have saved millions of lives.
Mumps, measles, the Asian flu
all those epidemics that killed hundreds of millions of people
are nearly all gone now.
Experimental vaccines were also used to fight Ebola.
And that epidemic has largely been contained.
The ultimate goal is to slam the brakes
on the virus’s ability to spread.
And building immunity is key.
At the moment one infected person gives it to
roughly three other people who each infect
three more and so on.
But if we create what’s called herd immunity
we can bring that right down.
The idea is for about 60% of people to become immune
to the coronavirus either by recovering from it
or getting vaccinated.
That way we reduce transmission from one person
to just one other person or less.
The key is to get to 60% as fast as possible.
That strain of the virus will now no longer be a threat
and it will go away.
But we aren’t there yet.
Which is why the experts say it’ll be a while
before life can return to normal.
If we have one-time social distancing
there’s a very good chance that a large number of people
will remain susceptible to infection.
It seems like naturally we're going to enter
into this intermittent social-distancing period.
And in order to reach a high enough level of immunity
in the population our model suggests
that it could take into 2022.
It's also worth remembering that until we get
those treatments and a vaccine most of us
around 80%
can rely on our own immune systems
to fight the coronavirus.
So the general advice is to stay healthy, eat well
sleep well and exercise even if you’re stuck at home.
Because that’s where we need to be right now
to protect people who are most at risk
while we all wait for the science to catch up.
“We don’t know when we’ll be back on
the Start Here set but not to worry.
We’re still going to be bringing you more episodes
any way we can.
In the meantime our website aljazeera.com
has all the latest on the coronavirus pandemic.
I’ll see you next week.”